ready to suit up Keano during this year
San Diego comic-con filmmaker and comic
book geek Kevin Smith had a chance to
chat with Avengers and game directors
Joe and Anthony Russo and the three of
them had a little chat about Keanu
Reeves place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe speculation over Reeves joining
the MCU has recently grown to a fever
pitch the actors career has been
enjoying a cellar resurgence thanks in
large part to the highly successful John
wick franchise and he and the MCU seem
like a match made in Hollywood heaven
yeah I'm taken aback Marvel Studios head
honcho Kevin Feige
recently threw fuel on the room of fire
by suggesting that Reeves has been
considered for virtually every movie
Marvel has ever made and that the only
reason he hasn't showed up so far is
that they simply haven't found the right
path for him if it were up to Smith and
the Russo brothers however Reeves would
be donning a white bodysuit cape and
cowl and stepping into the role of Mark
Specter otherwise known as Moon Knight
drawing that comic-con interview Smith
posed the simple questions of the Russo
brothers he would they like to see
Reeves play in the MCU much hemming and
whoring ensued with the Russos admitting
that the choices were pretty much
limitless before Smith offered up
moonlight as a spec prompting Joe Russo
to reply right that's a good call just
like Keanu it seems to be more of a
matter of when not AF moonlight will
eventually appear in the MCU considered
by some to be Marvel's answer to Batman
marc spector is a one-time mercenary who
suffers from dissociative identity
disorder on assignment in egypt he had a
transformative experience when his life
was spared by the ancient guard khonshu
in return he agreed to serve khonshu on
earth with the help of his right-hand
man Frenchie and a significant other
Marlene Specter uses his considerable
fortune to equip himself as a costumed
vigilante moon Knights becoming the bane
of a New York City criminal underworld I
the moons night of vengeance must carry
out your luminous will are you seriously
talking to the moon as in the cow jumped
over the character has long been a
favorite of Marvel comic fans and was
suggested early and often that he would
lend himself well to a Netflix series a
notion that sadly became moot when
Marvel television ended its relationship
with the streaming service in 2019 as
recently as last year however Feige
remark that moonlight is one of the
characters being eyed for a potential
MCU solo feature but there was no
mention of the character during the
recent reveal of Marvel's phase 4 slate
at comic-con
any such project isn't likely to come to
fruition for at least a few years
ultimately this makes it almost certain
that's when marc spector finally shows
up in the MCU he won't be portrayed by
Reeves sure the star was proven his
action skills or the John wick series
but when it comes to casting
marvelous in the midst of something of a
youth movement the studio famously likes
two signers featured players to multiple
Picture deals stretching over several
years which is part of the reason why
for example Feige has stated his
intention to go younger for the actors
he will eventually cast as the x-men and
since ends game will likely be the final
Marvel movie to be directed by Jaron
Anthony Russo based filmmakers basically
have no horse on the race as cool as it
would be to see Reeves Don munites cowl
it seems unlikely that the 54 year old
actor would be able to remain in the
role for the five to ten years at Marvel
with demand of him of course it goes
without saying that Feige and his team
are very very good at their jobs
and when Marvel finally announces Reeves
role in the MCU you can bet your bottom
dollar that it'll prove to be the
perfect match check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]